trois invités ce soir on va voir si vous
les connaissez bien vous faire lequel
des trois jeux vous propose des
anecdotes sur nos invités vous nous
dites à votre avis lequel des trois ça
concerne lequel des trois couper du bois
torse nu avec jean lassalle toit de quoi
oui en toi encore on peut citer la poste
et pour l'émission la baule d'antoine on
l'avait passé ici à bamako bonbons
sucrés ne la quitterai dans les muscles
très beau cadeau non mais je vais le jeu
coupe des bûches assez régulièrement
vous avez un beau torse donc je me dis
est-ce que vous entraînez neuronaux
nombreux touristes
il se renseigne direct renseigne pas ça
suffit non mais c'est vrai et beau gosse
oui oui franchement regardez regardez
bien
[Musique]
il m'a répondu avec sage
oui
défoncez du bois
je place à rais
d'ailleurs sa bague
le seul politique que je connais qui ai
fait ça c'est poutine mais on sort dans
les salles
que ça a été fait sciemment pour montrer
les muscles se taire en question est là
par contre à mon avis c'est ridicule
[Musique]
marester 100 adhérents politique avec
qui on se fait pas scier lequel des deux
a étudié le marketing
hakim michel betting doigts de marquer
si michel attractive c'est acquis mais
après lice et a fait des études de
marketing
oui malheureusement basse et ça m'a
servi pas grand chose
t'as fait quoi come back j'ai fait un
bac es économique et c'était après
marketing mais très rapidement
tout était très vite mal ouais non
invasif n'a jamais réussi les études
c'est pas mon fort vous avez fait quoi
vous michel
j'ai fait des lettres n'est trois
lettres comme belhadj en français mais
là il me soit la fédé lettre au ton toi
t'as fait quoi des lettres aussi ah
ouais oddo ce sont les mecs éditeurs
c'est vrai qu'on n'avait rien fait pour
bloquer federer je fais la même chose
bagley s'ébattent elles n'ont lettres
d'études au maire est d'accord attendez
un peu mis tous les mecs si je vous
disais les études que j'ai fait des
trucs des à la con j'ai choisi d'aider y
avait des unités de valeur qui voit là
j'ai choisi patriarcat y oui aux arcades
rivard qui y architecture hellénistique
et il en reste quelque chose mais oui je
peux reconnaître le style de certaines
poteries tél je vous ferai un quiz
poterie comme si chacun je le prépare
des dans la tête tu veux si la plus
unique au dos est déjà parti à champhol
kosari option mykonos alors vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa réserve et il est devant le but mais
il amène le fou surtout qu'il avait
indiqué c'est très possible
lequel des trois est chevalier de la
légion d'honneur michel bourrust et
c'est là qu'on en 2012 michel était il
est fait chevalier de la légion
d'honneur c'est là tu le mérites
j'ai dit vous n'êtes pas chevalier de
des uv d'honneur des saluts d'honneur
mais non rien vous n'êtes pas su manier
vous maintenant qu'à des sanctions non
non non plus les arts et les lettres
c'est bien et agricoles mérite agricole
en moi des méritas rouge et les poireaux
et à cause d'un film il a trouvé un film
parce que je sais c'est à cause d'eux je
trouve très beau de ma belle-mère et ça
a beaucoup plu aux agriculteurs quand le
mon agent m'a dit le ministère veut te
remettre ça j'ai dit c'est une blague
donc j'ai dit non c'est indécent par
rapport aux agriculteurs qui se révèle
au cul pour pas grand chose moi j'ai
fait un film bon et puis le messin
répondu non non c'est eux qui veulent ça
va ça va les vexer si vous refusez donc
j'ai accepté
j'en suis fier et en même temps gérer
par ces grand chose pour l'avoir mais
oui antoine le mérite agricole comment
est-ce que j'ai aidé à la réintroduction
d'une race chevaline en basse-normandie
trouville-sur-mer très précisément wii
qui servait à les carrioles à relever
les ordures voile alors tant mieux
les gars ça il va dire oui il y avait du
chocolat bill qu'il est con casta elsa
aller le breizh détroit le caire ap le
trottoir pascal obispo
lequel des trois affaires le trottoir
quand pascal aussi c'est sûrement michel
michaut hnarakis et ouais c'était dans
un sketch de l'émission c'était de
cuisine on sait qu'avant d'être une star
du grand écran à kim faisait des vidéos
pour tpm pays notamment avec ces séances
du micro trous oui pascal obispo étaient
en plateau et il a bien qui fait
regarder à khimki excellent voilà on l'a
roulé toujours kiffé regarde d'hakim
j'ai mon poto pascal obispo ça ça fait
plutôt plaisir on voit ce que les gens
pensent de lui dans la stricte
parce que c'est pas écrit dans les
livres dans l'ombre c'est le frère de
pascal obispo du oui mon domicile obispo
non je n'ai jamais entendu pas mal et je
compte les brésil en 2006 ah ouais parce
qu'elle le peut au bout d'chou reconnaît
ce monsieur
cette joute temps et l'abbaye les magic
system on a chip ans le mois vous avez
changé le gave à la cité pêche 3 où nos
vies on ne meurt qu'une fois çi kitchi
kitchi kitchi séjour il va peut-être
avant césar il vient il vient nous voir
voilà voilà
lequel des trois écrit le générique du
dessin animé cobra un cobra antoine
antoine et ouais a bien mondiale écrit
d'autres génériques notamment clémentine
lempire des 5
prix nous interprète également non j'ai
pas écrit lucky luke alors je n'avais
que je ne fais que la voix
[Applaudissements]
c'est à quel moment ils jaequi de la
chanson lui qui eut saisi sans antoine
de caunes qui s'assoit on vas tu fais la
voix de lucky luke c'est ça regèle
personnage c'est pas moi qui chante là
vous avez remarqué
alors on attend juste la voix du quai
que c'est beaucoup c'est un lucky luke
un effet atteint le score à peine un
talk over sur de la musique
d'accord on va chanter moi très bien
d'accord et enfin lequel des trois a été
champion d'europe de la gentillesse
michel blanc qui me fait me liront
antoine de caunes les trois sur horrible
de répondre elle est alors ça c'est
bénin elle prend des risques
tu sait recevoir
ouais c'est ça bah vous allez voir la
barre avoir sciemment de chira ces
messieurs lourd parce que tu rappelles
de sabaoui très bien c'était non merci
bernard jean michel ribes c'est ça en
gascon passe complètement cette armée et
ça est très drôle à faire si simple haut
d'europe de la gentillesse détient
notamment avec roland giraud ou et
gérard darmon garder il avait traversé
un jeu de vieille dame ou même ami
départ 13 à la française c'est parti
petit pain tente le tout pour le tout il
fait une traversée à rodez avec double
temps reste des mains sur le don de la
vieille pour la rassurer
et il termine à la française en sorties
d'église s'est pas triomphe alors puis
il heureux ouais
qu'est ce que ça fait d'être l'homme le
plus gentil d'europe et trois quoi
plaisir un plaisir ont le qi a également
sauté dessus on a du temps et de l'ère
philippe philippe le la prochaine étape
le titre mondiale de la gentillesse son
écoute jojo tu vas me lâcher un peu la
guibole a été question à la noix à ce
que moi le guignol j'ai pas que ça à
faire tu vois tu me laisses passer du
temps ici où je passe la tête
l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]